this is the brand-new 2019 iPad Mini and
this is a 2018 $329 iPad and today we're
comparing these bad boys we'll be taking
a look at the size screen quality
performance gaming Apple pencil use and
much more the 2018 standard iPad has
been extremely popular thanks to its
relatively fast processor Apple pencil
support and especially its $329 price
now that we have this powerhouse with
updated specs for only $70 more I would
say it's a no-brainer if you don't mind
the size but here's the dilemma you can
get the 2018 iPad for $150 cheaper
thanks to it consistently being on sale
for $250 we'll leave some links in the
video description if you're just reading
the spec sheet online and you're looking
at the nine point seven inch versus the
eight inch it doesn't seem like that big
of a deal but here clearly you can see
that the iPad Mini is much smaller and
honestly I was quite surprised when I
unboxed this this morning along with
that there is quite a difference in
weight in just the size and feel in the
hand you can see that I'm comfortably
holding this in my hand it would be very
easy to be watching something reading a
book and you kind of just won't get
tired of holding sin your hand it feels
really nice whereas the iPad has much
more bulk and weight and I can see you
definitely getting tired and wanting to
hold it with both hands the iPad Mini is
also thinner both in its case and the
bezels which is more pleasing to look at
so now let's compare the actual displays
the resolution is exactly the same but
since the iPad Mini is smaller all those
pixels are crammed into a smaller
display making it look sharper or more
detailed now it's not a huge difference
but it definitely is noticeable I have
Apple's website open up here especially
if you're somebody that likes nice sharp
and high resolution displays now you may
have noticed that the iPad Mini screen
is warmer than the standard iPad and
that's because it has true tone which
personally I wasn't that big of a fan of
when it came out but has really grown on
me I'll go ahead and shut that off just
for consistency the mini also supports
wide colors so it's more color accurate
now let's compare the maximum brightness
of both of these we have auto brightness
shut off and taking a look at these
side-by-side I don't know I may be the
mini slightly brighter but let's let the
camera decide since it's more accurate
what's interesting is that the iPad Mini
has more brightness shift so if you're
looking at it from an off angle it gets
much dimmer than the standard iPad which
keeps its brightness
another difference is reflectivity now
this is hard to show off in camera but
the 2018 iPad is much more reflective
and if I just look at myself like this
it looks like a mirror whereas the 2019
iPad Mini looks kind of matted out and
great even though it is a glossy screen
so you're gonna have less reflection
problems now the main reason for that is
the fact that this does not have a Lam
in a display and this one does this
means that there's an actual gap between
the glass and the actual LCD display and
this might be the biggest difference
that you notice day to day and that's a
reason why a lot of people didn't buy
this model of the iPad with the iPad
Mini the glass is actually laminated or
glued to the LCD display this leads to
many differences like better contrast
deeper blacks a more solid feeling
without a kind of a thumping sound when
you're touching the display and the gap
is actually quite noticeable especially
if you're looking at an angle and that
means that the experience of using an
Apple pencil is much better with iPad
Mini if you're using the 2018 iPad with
the Apple pencil sometimes the tip of
the pencil will actually be off from
where you're drawing so now let's get
into performance the iPad Mini 4 has the
same CPU and graphics as $1,000 iPhone
10s whereas a 2018 iPad has the same
processor as the iPhone 7
they're both rated for 10 hours of
battery life but the knurl engine inside
the 812 will help apps created with core
ml to launch faster run faster and use
much less power so you'll most likely to
use less battery life on the Mini
compared to the iPad the new iPad Mini
also has three gigs of RAM instead of
two with the standard 2018 iPad and
running Geekbench 4 we actually get
close to 40% faster score in single core
and almost 70% faster score in
multi-core as far as graphics we get
just over 50% higher metal score with
the iPad Mini but this is looking at a
lot of different compute asks so let's
run antutu we have a score that's over
75% faster with the iPad Mini but that's
an overall score if we take a look at
just the GPU score it's actually just
about two and a half times faster that
is incredible so that's going to show
you your real-world kind of gaming
performance let's take a look at that
with asphalt 9 so the colors in the
contrast looks great the brightness I'm
not seeing any performance dips and I
probably shouldn't since it has a 12
processor if everything's fluid and
everything seems nice and what's really
standing out
to me is how nice it is to use the iPad
Mini as far as size and weight it's very
comfortable in the hand and the screen
definitely is large enough to play games
it's a lot nicer than using my iPhone
one thing that I do wish is that we had
stereo speakers instead of just hearing
the sound from the bottom of the iPad so
now the standard iPad yes the screen is
bigger so you kind of get a fuller field
of view but I feel like since it's so
close to my actual face it doesn't help
me that much if I was playing a
different game where I'd have to look at
more area it'd kind of be hard since I'm
holding it so close one thing that I can
tell though is it's much heavier and
it's harder to hold in the hands because
of that if you're gonna do extended
gaming sessions say 20-30 minutes I
think you will start getting tired
holding it in your hands now as far as
the smoothness I don't want to say it's
not a smooth because I don't know if I
could tell that for sure but I
definitely can notice is that there's a
lot more aliasing all over in the
background on the actual vehicles and
maybe the graphics is worse overall or
maybe it's just all that aliasing that
it's not removing like it is with a
smaller iPad the other thing that really
stands out to me is the reflectivity I
definitely see it in the blacks
reflections from what's in the
background in my face
comparing these side-by-side I could
definitely tell that the iPad Mini is
smoother and we looked it up and
actually runs at 60fps on the mini and
it runs that 30 here the graphics look a
little bit better and the aliasing is
definitely much better and if I had to
choose between one of these for gaming
it would definitely be the iPad Mini I
have both iPads side-by-side the same
distance from me and now let's do a
speaker test let's start out with the
original iPad you guys let me know down
in the comments which one you think
sounds better
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I am personally surprised I
thought the larger iPad would maybe be
louder or fuller but it's actually the
opposite I think the iPad Mini just has
newer speakers or maybe a better design
or something like that it does sound a
bit louder to me but along with that
just the actual sound quality the
speakers do sound better the bass the
mids and especially the clarity and the
highs it definitely sounds better so
that's a win for the iPad Mini as far as
the cameras the ones on the back are
exactly the same but the selfie cameras
aren't we have a 1.2 megapixel on the
larger standard iPad and a 7 megapixel
on the iPad Mini just looking at him
side-by-side I could definitely tell a
difference let me take a selfie for you
guys you let me know what you think in
the comments and as far as selfie video
the 2018 I've had just record 720p
compared to 1080p with the new iPad Mini
before I give you guys my
recommendations I want to list a few
more spec differences the new iPad Mini
has Bluetooth 5 and also simultaneous
dual band Wi-Fi which means we'll get a
faster and more reliable Wi-Fi
connection and if you're gonna get the
LTE model you'll have gigabit class LTE
which will be faster on the iPad Mini if
you like the size and don't mind
spending more money especially if you
want to use an Apple pencil by the Mini
the display is great and the CPU and
graphics are the same as $1,000 iPhone
10s you can't find a small tablet this
good anywhere so we would highly
recommend it now if price does matter to
you you can find the 2018 ipad for $250
which will leave a few links to
different sites that often have sales in
the video description below this is a
steal especially if you like the larger
size if you're not doing very intensive
tasks like gaming we think that most
people will be happy with it this has
been max with max tech click right here
if you want to subscribe and see our
full comparison between all of the iPads
the Apple offers right now thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]